[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today all right
up next we have Logan here in Nashville
hey Logan welcome to the
show hi Rachel how are you we are doing
well how can we
help yeah I wish I was better than I
deserved a what's up sorry Logan what's
going on I'm just kidding
okay um anyway um So currently
um I do have uh some debt I got to deal
with um and I never thought I would
actually be calling into the
show um after all these years but um So
currently I do have some uh credit card
debt um I have a little bit student
loans left I am married my wife has a
little bit of student loan debt too but
basically this year we've had a we've
had a lot of trouble with cash flow um
her
um her jobs not you know just basically
paying her by check she was working
remotely and okay things kind of fell
behind and um feeling the stress I think
yeah we are feeling the stress um and we
actually in our and I mean this lightly
because um our marriage did kind of uh
was a little bit on the Rocks but you
know we both want to make things work
out so I guess the best way to go
forward about this because I mean I know
I've got a little bit of I probably got
a few years as far as an uphill battle
as far as debt yeah um the snowball debt
and everything but how can I get
her um on board with this without feel
with you know on the same page as me uh
without feeling you know so anxious and
everything and um basically I suggest my
question yeah okay so just a couple of
just tactical questions Logan how much
do you guys make a
year um so I make around 48 on one job
uh I am taking I am taking a second
part-time job
so um and she makes around 38
okay all right so and then um before
taxes before taxes sure and then how
much debt is how much debt are we
talking how much student loan debt
combined and credit cards
combined uh so my student loan is 6,000
um which is not bad I mean it's just I
haven't paid it a couple years mainly
because well we won't get into it you
had to
yeah yeah but then how
much uh hers is around 17 okay how much
credit card do you guys have uh 13 uh
that's over two cards one is uh one is
approaching the max out and the the
culprit of it
is uh you know our rent's $1,700 a month
right now and uh there were times hold
on hold on hold on Logan Logan Logan not
the culprit not the
culprit I'm listening to you talk and
you have very distant language from
reality here's what I mean by that we
had some trouble with cash flow no y'all
didn't make enough money and you spent
too
much the main culprit is the rent it's
not it's not the main culprit is we have
chosen to make 38 and 40 and not work
one job two job three jobs we've chosen
to live in a city I all of the healing
that has to happen in this household is
going to start with y'all both choosing
reality right and not living in this
this world is descending Upon Us in all
these ways no dude we're going to take
it right by the horns and say what is
real and what is not what is real is we
are broke what is real is dude you don't
have a ton of debt you have too much but
I thought you were going to say 150,000
th the way you're just sounding like
Eeyore like oh well it's all coming down
bro it's not you know what I mean it
feels like it by my standards because
this wasn't a problem two years ago and
I mean yeah but you stop being
intentional yeah exactly that's
it yeah why'd you stop being
intentional um I don't know I'm just
thinking about like why just be just
give me a straight right on answer why
did you stop being
intentional I guess it's because I cared
too much because the thing is this was a
this was a philosophy you know Dave's
philosophy was something that was
important to me and then I found myself
in this position but I guess what I
didn't do was make sure that uh I did
the necessarily necessary things to keep
us out of this
position um perfect that's the kind of
ownership you need moving forward
because now you're going to right yeah
yes what and what's your wife's
hesitation because I know you were
asking about the marriage part of that
what is her why is she why is she
hesitant well she's never
really I see best way to put this um
just say it just say it just say
it she's not she's never really focused
on this aspect of life just okay so
she's a free spirit she's a spender she
doesn't really want to be bogged down
with the
details right at at least she used to be
worse um but obviously this past couple
of years she's saying okay we need to do
something yeah yeah Logan there's a
there's a feeling I'm having and I could
be totally off base because even the way
you're talking about the marriage your
marriage and then the money stuff
there's just a level of kind of like
life is just happening to us and kind of
a level of
apathy that starts to kind of just sink
in and you kind of just become going
with the flow and there's not this and
I'm not saying you have to live your
entire life intense 24/7 but realizing
that people that win in life that have a
healthy marriage doesn't just happen
right they work on it they go to therapy
they read books they sit down with
couples that have a marriage that they
want they they practice communication
they they fight about I mean like they
they do the work with money people that
win with money it doesn't just happen
like they are so focused so intentional
right so there's there's this level of
intensity I kind of just like want to
shoot through the air right now to you
and your wife to be like you guys can do
this like your numbers and especially if
you get a second job like you guys can
make real progress but you have to care
like you have to get in this place and I
think you may be there where you're
realizing oh my gosh I don't know where
else to go that's why you're calling us
but there's this um this intensity that
I want you guys to have that's going to
help you get through this process this
laxas kind of attitude
it kind of just you you kind of end up
getting what you're getting and that's
and nothing changes there has to be some
level of deep change for you guys and
there's a level of passion there for
life for your marriage for your money
like all of this to do it on purpose
right and and I would want you and your
wife to be on that same page and working
towards that same value system that same
goal this sounds like I'm going to come
out of left field do you exercise
dude um I do every day I'm a delivery
driver so it feels like it
like what do you get passionate
about um well honestly about music
because I am a musician and that's why I
came to Nashville and I actually uh I
actually made a living as a
self-employed musician for years when
the pandemic happened and I kind of went
in other directions okay but I still
play well I want you to deal with the
loss of that of that identity that who
you are and that I'm I'm guessing Rachel
there is a sense of just kind of lost at
sea yeah and good for you I know some
musicians who just sit on their hands
good for you for getting out there and
throwing boxes to put food on your table
that's amazing but I want you to find
some Vigor again like Rachel said like
find some passion some intensity sit
down with your wife and hold both of her
hands and say let's do this you can do
it